[Music]  formal this simple technique find a  quiet place visualize your goal and  remember that you are amazing confidence  is an armor against the world says  medium service yeah with the ghost tones  this is my sister along with a gift  repeat your goal in your mind here's the  plan  Angela will pretend she sees a ghost  will put on a damn good show and make  some money  you said you heard screaming yes angry  told you I just wanted a quiet house if  you can control the situation mister  suddenly you can influence others I've  come to see if you'll consider leaving  this house is this your usual routine  for all your clients  so all enact angeles gift you're here  that something's here did you see her  but really thought you could help me  it's just house will you not give up  time I thought if you could hear the  voices he'd be able to stop them  [Applause]  and remember that you are amazing  [Music]